Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today, I’m going to explain an action science
fiction film called “Bad Land: Road to Fury.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, we see a large
barren land.
A young man named Jerome Holm, narrates to
us that he hasn’t seen this land when it
was green, but his father has.
Years ago, it used to be home to several farmers
who grew wheat and grains on it.
However, after drought struck the land, not
a single plant has been able to grow.
Most of the farmers left the place but Jerome's
father, Ernest, hoped the land would be green again.
He still believes that it just needs some
water.
But in this world, people kill each other
for water.
In the first scene, we see two muggers trying
to break into a tiny house.
Earnest catches them and kills the first one.
The second mugger tries to convince him to
spare his life, but is killed when he secretly
takes a gun out.
His son, Jerome, insists he could have helped
him.
The house the muggers were breaking into,
has an old water pump that stops working when
Ernest tries to use it.
With no water left, the father and son make
their way on a mule to the “waterman”,
people who extract water from deep wells through
a government deal.
Ernest exchanges supply with those people
for water.
He has been trying to convince them to provide
him with water to cultivate a small part of
his land for years.
However, the watermen only do it for the right
amount of money that Ernest cannot afford.
On their way back, their mule falls down and
breaks its leg.
Earnest reluctantly shoots the animal dead.
The two come back home to Jerome’s sister,
Mary, serving them bag food.
Because of water scarcity, we see Mary cleansing
the dishes with soil.
The following day, Jerome and Ernest visit
Sam Lever's auction house to get something
to replace the mule who died.
There, a robotic carrier machine called Simulit
Shadow (Sim) catches their eyes.
Ernest wins the auction against a man named
Flem Lever, who also happens to be Sam’s son.
Flem is having an affair with Mary, unknown
to Ernest and Jerome.
The two then go to meet Jerome’s sick mother,
Katherine Holm.
She lives in a nearby hospital where she can
walk while wired to a special frame.
Since the frame is too expensive, they cannot
bring her home.
Jerome spends his time with his mother that
day; Ernest and Katherine kiss goodbye and seperate.
On their way back, Ernest and Jerome stop
at a gas station.
We see Ernest take a gulp of petrol after
pumping it into his vehicle.
The two encounter a couple with a young baby,
begging for water.
The father, Robbie, wants to sell the baby
because they cannot afford to take care of
him, but Ernest advises against it and tells
him that he’ll help them with water.
Robbie knows of Flem and Mary’s affair,
and hints Earnest towards it.
At home, Ernest confronts Mary about her sneaking
out frequently, but she claims that it is
her freedom and tells her father that she
hates him.
She tries running away, but Ernest locks her
in her room and nails her windows shut.
One morning, Ernest and Jerome wake up to
Sim absent from its shed.
Someone had stolen it.
Ernest assumes it was Flem and goes to his
house, but finds out from Sam, that he has
left with a truck that morning for the mountains.
Ernest then goes looking for him to the watermen,
but they knock him unconscious.
When he regains consciousness, it is already
night.
The watermen accuse him of stealing their
supplies.
Ernest insists that he didn’t steal them,
but their leader, Caleb, attacks him.
They fight for a while, but Ernest manages
to get his hands on his rifle and run away from there.
On his way back home, he discovers Flem sleeping
on the road with sim by his side, it is clear
that he had stolen the machine and the watermen’s
supplies.
Earnest points the rifle at him, holds him
hostage, then ties him to the machine.
He wants to take Flem back to the watermen
to prove his innocence.
On their way, Flem makes comments about Mary,
which angers Ernest.
After walking for a while, both of them get
thirsty.
Flem persuades Ernest to use the water from
the watermen’s supply.
The two sit down to drink water and chat.
Flem then tries to convince Ernest to let
him go, and they can share the money, but
Ernest is adamant about getting him caught.
Ernest is weak and limp, he clearly cannot
walk another mile to the waterman.
Flem knows this, so he strikes Ernest with
a stone, making him hit his head on a cliff.
His head starts to bleed uncontrollably and
is knocked unconscious.
Ernest wakes up to him being tied instead
of Flem.
Flem pours water into Ernest’s mouth as
he screams.
Later, we see Flem arrive at Ernest’s house
in his motorbike to take Mary.
She happily runs out to him.
Earnest still hasn’t been home, so Jerome
goes out to look for him.
He finds the machine alone on the way.
When he reaches the watermen, they inform
him of Ernest’s death.
Everyone assumes that it was caused by the
machine.
In the following scene, we see everyone mourning
Ernest’s death at his funeral.
Later, Kathrine and the kids cry in her hospital
bed.
When they come out, Flem picks them up in
his truck.
After Ernest's death, Flem has now become
the mentor of the family.
He calms Jerome down as he hits Sim for killing
his father.
Later, he tells him that Mary is pregnant
with his child and that he loves her.
Jerome accepts their relationship.
Later that day, Flem goes to the watermen
and talks to them about sending water to Ernest’s land.
Caleb laughs at his idea, but gets defensive
when Flem blames him for Ernest’s death.
Flem also shows him a knife with Caleb’s
name that was found with Ernest’s body.
Scared to be accused, Caleb agrees to divert
water to their field.
Everyone is happy when the land gets its first
sprinkle of water.
Flem works day and night to grow wheat on
the land.
A few months later, they are fully grown.
Flem gets married to Mary and currently livz
at Ernest's home with Jerome and Mary.
One day, his father, Sam, with some men from
the bank approaches their house, threatening
to take the land because of Ernest's debt.
The debt is too much for Flem to pay, so he
takes the machine with him and approaches
his friend Robbie that night.
He knows about Robbies intention to sell his
child so he persuades Robbie to come with
him, just to see how much a baby can be worth.
However, when they reach there, Robbie realizes
that Flem has secretly made a deal with the
people to sell his baby.
The people try to take the baby away, Robbie
resists it and is shot dead by Flem.
This causes a shootout between the dealers
and Flen runs away with the money.
However, the machine, Sim, is shot and damaged.
This activates the auto mode in the machine
which causes it to return back to its manufacturer,
Calvin Hooyman.
The following day, Flem pays the bank from
the money he sold the child with.
Jerome assumes that the money came by selling
sim, so no one suspects anything.
In the following scene, we see Sim limping
its way back to Calvin, who lives across the border.
Calvin calls the number inscribed on Sim and
reaches Holm's residence.
He talks to Jerome about the machine coming
back to him, which shocks Jerome, because
Flem had told him he sold it to Robbie.
Jerome asks Flem if Robbie sold Sim’s parts
and it somehow made to the owner, but Flem
gets annoyed at him for the question and dismisses
it.
Then, he tells them he is going to meet his
mother that evening, but instead he plans
to cross the border to meet Calvin, the manufacturer
of Sim.
Later, he reaches the border, but the guard
stops him because he is too young to cross it.
A girl named Anna calls him over, and tells
him she knows a way he can go to the other side.
In exchange for money, she puts him in a vehicle
with chickens and sends him over.
They meet again at the other side and separate.
Jerome then goes to meet Calvin.
There, Calvin shows him all the functions
of the machine.
He also shows that the machine’s eyes are
cameras, that were made to capture the slope
for reforestation.
The camera has captured all that the machine
has seen.
Jerome plays the recordings and sees his time
with Ernest.
As he goes through it, he is horrified to
see that Flem was the one who killed Ernest.
That day, after Ernest had gained consciousness,
Flem tied him to the machine and set its destination
to the watermen.
The machine had dragged an injured but alive
Ernest to his death.
By the end of the video, tears roll down Jerome’s
eyes.
In the evening, he returns home, but doesn’t
confront Flem about anything.
One day, Flem and Jerome are hunting deers,
after which Jerome keeps the rifle with him,
hiding it under his bed for the future.
At breakfast, Jerome tells Flem about Robbie
calling him.
Flem is surprised and accuses Jerome of lying,
because he knows Robbie is already dead.
Later, Flem receives a letter, written by
Jerome as Robbie.
The letter asks Flem to meet Robie at the
same place he has killed Ernest.
He is confused by this, but he decides to
find out whether Robie is still alive.
Later at night, Flem tells a pregnant Mary
that he has to go out to sell something.
Mary wishes him luck, and asks him to come
back soon.
When Flem reaches the place, he calls for
Robbie.
As he walks, he falls down a pit and breaks
his legs.
He lies there calling for help, when Jerome
appears in front of him.
Seeing him there, Flem takes a sigh of relief
and asks him for help.
However, Jerome stands there with a rock in
his hand.
Flem realizes that he knows everything that
happened and apologizes to him, claiming it
was just an accident.
He begs him to spare his life for Mary and
their child, but Jerome doesn’t listen.
He points the rifle at Flem and shoots him
dead.
It has been two days since the event.
Mary is worried about her husband, but Jerome
asks her to wait a little more.
He has decided to keep Mary in the dark about
both Ernest’s and Flem’s death.
Mary suggests they bring their mother home,
because they now have the money to afford
the wringing system she lives in.
The movie ends as Jerome erases all the video
memory from Sim.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank you for watching.